Previously on Brothers & Sisters 2x
I just gowin away for anotha trip
And I decided nawt to uplode durin dis tiem
So owl see u in seven days
And so it continues...
Poods did 9/11
Swedish Fangirls
Felix for pope
lol nvm it wasn't 9/11
Felix wins Olympics
I Cri Evrytiem
HONEY I'M HOME!
WHO TF IS THIS?!
Jesus Christ, that's Jason Bourne!
Maybe next time >:D
Look who has returned
For too long he was missing
For too long, he let his people suffer
I'm back
OH GOD NOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!
NO! No, go away!
The long wait is finally over!
I am back!!
Let's see how da bros managed to survive without me
Let's see how they reacted to me being gone!
*Reads*
"7 days without cancer" RIP
*Reads some more*
"Pewds 2013..."
*Zooms in*
That's just one comment
"Hey remember than one time Pewds was funny?"
WHAT IS THIS!!!???
Sllloowww moootttiiioonn
*voiceover* You're supposed to be upset!
Why am I here?
What's the point? Wh- Why did I come back? Why? I don't-
Pewds? You probably shouldn't read the next one :/
"Yay the lil fuck of YouTube is gone for a week"
Goddammit!
Warned ya!
"So he literally just left YouTube..."
Yeah, that's pretty much it!
I mean I might as well! No one seems to care!
NO ONE CARES AISLEY!!
(Aisley): I care :(
"This is kind of a copy of Casey Neisat"
Sub to Jacksepticeye he's way better!
Because Casey Neisat took a break, and I took a break, I'm copying him.... You must be retarded
Ah- I can say retarded now, my channel is uh...
AIN'T NO MERCY, GOT DAT PURPLE LAMBORGHINI LURKIN' ROSSAYY
Edgy now
Edgy? More like Cancerous!
See nothing happened
"Pewds I wish you had a great trip and put some work to your hair"
That's it...
THAT'S IT! THAT'S GENIUS!!
How could I have been so blind?
Of course!
Colored hair clickbait!
*laughter* Sike, okay, yeah, I didn't really dye my hair, this is clickbait!
I can tell this isn't about to go well for Pewds or me.
#PrayForTheCCGuy
That's how I'll win them back
(Weird Slideshow comes outta nowhere)
Hey everyone! Welcome I am DanTD- Whoops, wrong channel, Awkward...
*sigh*...For fuck's sake.